l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la parole est à madame
Béatrice Decamp pour le groupe liberté
indépendantre m et territoire merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre du
Travail de la santé des solidarités
madame la ministre je souhaite vous
interroger sur l'octroit de congés payés
pendant une période d'arrêt maladie et
sur l'impact de la rétroactivité de ce
droit pour l'ensemble de nos entreprises
et particulièrement pour les PME la Cour
de Cassation considère depuis le 13
septembre dernier que les salariés
peuvent acquérir des congéss payés
pendant leur arrêt maladie suivant ainsi
une directive européenne datée de 2003
qui n'a pas été transposé dans le droit
français il n'est bien évidemment pas
question ici de remettre en cause le
droit des salariés mais de pouvoir
trouver des solutions pour les très
petites entreprises et les PME en
particulier qui qui sont mises en
difficulté par cette mesure la
Confédération des PME le 17 novembre
dernier demandait d'ailleurs dans un
communiqué de presse au gouvernement de
limiter cette
rétroactivité de plafonner le nombre de
jours de congé payés acquis dans ce
cadre et de faire en sorte que le coût
ne soit pas à la seule charge de
l'employeur j'ai rencontré la semaine
dernière un patron d'une petite
entreprise dans ma circonscription qui
était concernée par le sujet pour sa
salariée qui est en arrêt maladie depuis
3 ans il doit débourser une somme
conséquente qui représente 10 % de sa
marge il n'a pas pu faire la nécessaire
action en amont pour que cette charge
soit étalée si cela se reproduisait il
pourrait devoir licencier des personnes
pour pouvoir payer la somme demandée il
semble que le gouvernement de Madame
borne a bien identifié ce problème et
souhaité se mettre en conformité avec le
droit européen tout en veillant à
préserver son impact sur les entreprises
je souhaiterais donc savoir où en sont
vos travaux et comment vous comptez
assurer les droits des salariés tout en
préservant les petites et moyennes
entreprises pour lesquelles plus
l'attente est longue plus les
difficultés s'accumule je vous remercie
je vous remercie ma cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Catherine vautterin
ministre du Travail de la santé et des
solidarités merci madame la Présidente
madames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Béatrice Descamp merci madame
la députée de revenir sur cet arrêt de
la Cour de cassation comme vous venez de
le dire du 13 septembre dernier qui
effectivement a est un arrêt extrêmement
important puisqu'il met en avant le fait
que la législation française n'est pas
en conformité avec le droit européen le
sujet vous venez vous-même de l'exprimer
madame la députée il s'agit de la
capacité pour les salariés des
entreprises de continuer à acquérir des
jours de congé alors même qu'ils sont en
en arrêt de travail quelle que soit la
durée et la pathologie à partir de là je
me permettrais de rajouter un élément de
contexte c'est qu'il y a une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité qui a
été déposée dont nous ne connaissons pas
aujourd'hui la réponse du Conseil
constitutionnel élément important bien
évidemment dans la réflexion qui est la
nôtre pour le reste évidemment
premièrement notre pays se mettra
évidemment en conformité avec la
législation européenne deuxièmement les
conséquences financières évidemment sont
très importante pour les entreprises les
TPE les PME et l'ensemble de nos
entreprises vous avez raison Madame la
Députée c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous ne pouvons que travailler avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
c'est-à-dire les représentants des
salariés bien sûr et les représentants
des entreprises c'est en tout cas le
sens dans lequel je souhaite aller dans
un délai qui sera évidemment le plus
court possible eu égard à cette grande
interrogation pour nos entreprises mais
aussi pour les salariés je vous remercie
madame
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Xavier
Breton pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Premier Ministre
nous avons été nombreux à être
profondément choqué à la mi-décembre par
la décision du président de la Cour des
comptes de différer de repousser la
publication d'un rapport sur
l'immigration rapport particulièrement
sévère sur la politique par rapport à la
politique de lutte contre immigration
irrégulière pour tenter d'expliquer
cette décision le président de la plus
haute juridiction des comptes publicqus
a indiqué benedointement qu'il ne
souhaitait pas
influencer le vote des parlementaires
mais quelle conception monsieur
moscovissi se fait-il des députés et les
sénateurs considè-t-il que nous ne
soyons pas assez mature pour prendre
connaissance et pour analyser un rapport
juste-il que nous ne soyons pas CAPAES
de comprendre les écrits et la pensée
des magistrats financiers de la rue
Cambour et si nombre de nos concitoyens
ont été également choqués c'est parce
qu'ils y retrouvent le mépris de ce
qu'on appelle parfois l'état profond le
mépris de cette prétendue élite
technocratique à l'égard des
représentants du peuple notre président
de groupe Olivier marlex vient de
demander au président de la commission
des finances notre collègue coqurel
qu'il organise l'audition du président
de la Cour des comptes du côté du
gouvernement nous attendons une
condamnation ferme Monsieur le Premier
Ministre désapprouvez-vous le mépris du
président de la Cour des comptes à
l'égard du Parlement et qui va à
l'encontre de nos
institutions je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame Marie Lebec ministre en
charge des relations avec le
Parlement merci monsieur le député
Xavier Breton pour cette question et
avant de démarrer ma ma réponse je
voudrais excuser le ministre Gérald de
Darmanin qui est en déplacement à la
Réunion au côté de nos compatriotes
suite au passage du du cyclone vous
interrogez le gouvernement sur le
rapport de la Cour des comptes sur la
politique de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière publiée le 14 janvier 2024
comme vous le savez la Cour des Comptes
est une juridiction financière dont
l'indépendance est garantie
constitutionnellement et elle définit
toute son en toute indépendance le
programme de ses contrôles et leur
déroulement il n'appartient donc pas au
gouvernement de se prononcer sur le
calendrier et la date de publication de
ce rapport sur le fond de votre question
le gouvernement se félicite que la cour
soulligne que la France est le pays
d'Europe qui exécute le plus
d'éloignements forcés en Europe avec
14235 éloignements forcés en 2022 pour
la France devant l'Allemagne la Suède
l'Espagne ou encore l'Italie la priorité
donnée à l'éloignement des étrangers
constituant une menace pour l'ordre
public a permis d'expulser 4686
étrangers délinquant en 2023 contre 3615
en 2022 les constats formulés par ce
rapport sur les leviers à activer pour
améliorer le le nombre de reconduites
sont assez largement connu vous le savez
puisque d'autres rapports ont été menés
par l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat à
ce su sujet c'est la raison pour
laquelle le projet de loi initial du
gouvernement déposé au Sénat le 1er
février 2023 comprenait déjà des mesures
fortes pour lever ces blocages les
mesures pour simplifier les contentieux
de l'éloignement lever les protections
dont bénéficient certains étrangers qui
constitue une menace à l'ordre public ou
encore alléger les charges pour les
policiers et les gendarmes l'orientation
du gouvernement pour lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière et clair comme
le sont les moyens inédits votés par le
Parlement à l'occasion de la loi
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur je pense notamment à la
création de 3000 places supplémentaires
et dans 11 nouveaux centres de CRRA et
le renforcement des services étrangers
des préfectures qui bénéficieront de 3/4
des créations en 2024 je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur breton oui merci madame la
ministre pour cette réponse que vous
faites sur le débat sur l'immigration
encore une fois ce rapport est très
sévère sur la politique contre
l'immigration irrégulière mais la
question question c'est effectivement le
rôle de la Cour des comptes dans nos
institutions vous évoquez l'indépendance
de la Cour des comptes bon on remarquera
qui le président est nommé par le
Président de la République les
institutions prévoient mais enfin c'est
il l'a choisi en tout cas et je voudrais
citer l'article 472 de notre
Constitution qui est explicite la Cour
des comptes assiste le Parlement dans le
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
ainsi que dans l'évaluation des
politiques publiques manifestement ils
ont manqué leur devoir je vous remercie
monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame anè Carel pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adressait au ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outresères qui est absent comme
on le sait puisqu'il a dû se rendre à la
réunion en raison des événements
météorologiques ma question s'adressera
donc à madame la ministre de l'Éducation
Nationale de la Jeunesse des sports des
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
madame la ministre après une année 2023
particulièrement intense l'année 2024
s'annonce très chargé pour l'ensemble de
nos forces de l'ordre avec les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques mais aussi
avec le parcours de la flamme du 8 mai
jusqu'à l'inauguration du 26 juillet
sans oublier le 80e anniversaire du
débarquement en Normandie et bien
d'autres événements prévus mais aussi
aussi ceux inattendus pour ne citer
qu'un exemple l'unité de CRS 32
installée dans ma circonscription à côté
du Havre sur Sainte Adresse a été
mobilisé 235 jours en 2023 bien plus que
l'année précédente avec des déplacements
de plus en plus lointains comme
grenobble Marseille ou Nice l'année 2024
s'annonce tout aussi chargé sinon plus
face à un calendrier complexe pour eux
et leur famille si tous les membres de
nos forces de l'ordre sont engagés avec
professionnalisme et ils m'en ont
d'ailleurs fait part récemment ils n'en
demortent pas moins que leurs
inquiétudes se focalise notamment sur la
prise en charge de leurs enfants pendant
leur affectation durant les Jos et c'est
bien compréhensible la quasi totalité
d'entre eux ne pourront pas prétendre à
des vacances pendant cette période
estivale il serait normal norm que leurs
enfants soient prioritaires pour accéder
au centre de loisirs centre aéré crèch
et garderies mais aussi colonies de
vacances afin qu'ils ne soi pas privé de
loisirs pendant leur période et pendant
le fait que leurs parents seront
pleinement
mobilisés madame la ministre quelle
mesure compte pendant le Gouvernement
compte prendre pardon le gouvernement en
lien avec les représentants de ces
professions pour rassurer ces
professionnels qui sont aussi des
parents afin qu'ils exercent leur
fonction l'esprit rassuré pour leur
immense service rendu à la nation
pendant cette période de jeu et de
réjouissance notre gouvernement mercire
leur doit bien en amont merci ma chère
collègue la parole est à Madame Amélie
oua casterra ministre de l'Éducation
Nationale de la Jeunesse des sports des
Jeux olympiques et
[Applaudissements]
paralympiques madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Carelle votre question est
l'opportunité pour moi de saluer
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
intérieure pour leur mobilisation
exceptionnelle tout au long de l'année
au service de la société au service de
l'école au service du sport la réussite
des JO repose sur une mobilisation
exceptionnelle des agents du ministère
de l'Intérieur en particulier nos
policiers et gendarmes pour la seule
cérémonie d'ouverture 45000 d'entre eux
seront sur le terrain il leur sera
effectivement demandé une présence
maximale entre le 15 juin et le 15
septembre allant jusqu'à 100 % au cœur
de l'événement du 24 4 juillet au 11
août pour concilier engagement et vie
personnelle le ministre de l'Intérieur a
annoncé aux agents qu'il pourrait
prendre jusqu'à 2 semaines de congé sur
cette période au-delà de cet enjeu des
congés Gérald armanin a reçu les
organisations syndicales de gardiens de
la paix ce lundi pour entendre leurs
autres demandes s'agissant des questions
de rémunération il présentera d'ici la
fin du mois de janvier l'accompagnement
prévu en terme de prime et de paiement
des heures supplémentaires des annonces
seront enfin faites sur les dispositifs
d'action sociale qui permettront pr
l'accueil de la petite enfance et les
séjours pour les enfants ce qui sera
particulièrement précieux pour les
familles monoparentales ou les couples
d'agents mobilisés tout ce travail sur
l'aménagement du temps de travail les
compensations indemnitaires et
l'accompagnement des familles est
également conduit par chaque ministère
par tous les ministères pour tous leurs
agents mobilisés pendant les jeux et ces
agents madame la députée votre question
est pour moi l'occasion de les saluer de
les remercier eux qui depuis 2017
construisent la réussite des jeux au
quotidien merci merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame
Christine Engrand pour le rassemblement
national madame la madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues en
2012 au Sénat Robert slump cadre au sein
du service de l'État hollandais dédié à
la gestion de l'eau expliqué que la clé
de notre réussite réside moins dans les
ouvrages même que dans notre service de
notre système organisationnel légal et
financier force de constater que 12 ans
plus tard l'échec du gouvernement les
les désarrois des milliers de personnes
inondées à deux reprises et bien et bien
et bel et bien pardon organisationnel
légal et financier tout le monde a pu
constater que vous ne savez pas quoi
faire pour sortir de la crise que vous
n'êtes pas compétent et que le droit
européen vous empêche vous ne savez pas
quoi faire sinon vous n'auriez pas
attendu 2 mois avant de préciser les
conditions d'éligibilité des
agriculteurs aux indemnisations pour les
pertes de récoltees et de vous rendre
compte que les maréchés n'étaient pas
inclus dans le dispositifs d'aide vous
n'êtes pas compétent et l'UE vous
empêche car 2 mois plus tard vous leur
offrez un cadeau empoisonné vous dé
débloquez les aides des minimis que le
droit européen plafonne à 20000 € sur 3
années par exploitation autrement dit
entravé par l'UE vous anéantissez les
possibilités pour les maréchés Français
qui seront indemnisés de leur sinistre
au titre des minimis de recevoir des
subventions pour se développer pendant
les trois prochaines années cette
solution injuste aurait pu être évité si
vous aviez agi lors des premières
inondations en effet l'indemnisation des
calamité agricole est permise par les
traités autrement si les conditions pour
déclencher ces calamités agricooles
n'étaient pas réunies vous pouviez tout
de même monter une aide dédiée au
sinistre validé au plus tard 3 mois
après sa notification au conseil et
alors peut-être que nos maréchés
bénéficieraient aujourd'hui d'une aide
qui n'obert pas leur activité pour
indemniser les dégâts d'une catastrophe
naturelle contre laquelle ils n'ont même
pas la possibilité de s'assurer je
précise bien peut-être car une fois de
plus la décision finale revient à
l'Union européenne monsieur le ministre
que vont devenir tous ces gens dont vous
vous apprêtez à saboter l'activité avec
l'Europe des nations une France
souveraine ne se poserait même pas la
question
merci je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Priska t ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du
gouvernement merci madame la présidente
madame la députée
Engrand je profite de votre question et
à ce titre je vous remercie pour votre
question pour remercier saluer
l'ensemble des hommes et des femmes qui
se sont mobilisés dans le cadre
effectivement de ces inondations
exceptionnelles qui ont eu lieu aussi
bien en novembre dernier qu'en ce début
d'année dans le département du ptecala
et à l'ouest du département du Nord je
salue bien évidemment nos forces
national que sont les forces de sécurité
et de secours mais également l'ensemble
des élus locaux mais permettez-moi aussi
d'avoir un mot puisque vous avez parlé
d'Europe non pas pour les dénoncer mais
pour saluer le travail de nos amis
Slovaques notamment polonais qui sont
venus en renfort de nos populations
nationales et je pense qu'il est aussi
important de rappeler que l'Europe n'est
pas un ennemi mais bien un une démarche
de solidarité si c'est la question merci
ça vous gêne mais je vais le répéter oui
l'Europe nous devons en être fier et
notamment quand elle vient en renfort de
la France pour répondre à court terme à
la situation d'urgence que connaissent
ces territoires des travaux de remise en
état des cours d'eau et Canau ont été
engagé dès lundi notamment le curage du
canal d'autrui ou encore le nettoyage et
les retraits des embacles sur l' par
ailleurs l'achat d'une station de
pompage installée dans la commune de
cuinchi financée par le fond vert et le
fond Barnier est d'ors et déjà programmé
nous avons également demandé au services
d'inspection de l'état de procéder à
trois missions d'évaluation la première
vise à estimer les dégâts causés par les
biens de collectivité la seconde a été
confiée au maire de Saint-Omer a été
rappelée hier par le Président de la
République et la troisième vise à
travailler sur la prévention des
inondations par ailleurs ce sujet est
hautement important et pour pour preuve
acte fort le premier déplacement du
Premier ministre Gabriel hatal a été
fait justement dans ce département sur
ces territoires et comme il l'a dit et
comme il le répète il ira fin du mois
début du mois prochain pour justement
être au côté des populations sinistrées
merci merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
Président riman pour le groupe
GDR merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre de l'Intérieur et des autres
mères est aujourd'hui au abonnés absent
mais nous ne lui entiendons pas rigueur
car il se trouve au côté de nos
compatriotes réonnais qui ont à se
remettre de la violence du cyclone Bilal
nous leur adressons nos pensées nos
solidarités notre fraternité tiens bon
pas quant à l'audace cette fameuse
audace que le Président de la République
nous présente comme la ligne directrice
de cette nouvelle a macronienne elle est
décrédibilisée d'entrer jeux car peu
courageuse et encore moins téméraire
l'audace la vraie aurait été de rétablir
un ministère de plein 6 dédié à tout ce
qui constitue les singularités qui font
le territoire trans
transocéanique pourtant les nombreuses
et diverses question ultramarine reste
au côté du logement de la santé des
transports sur le ban touche pas un mot
pour les autres mes lors de la locution
d'Emmanuel Macron mais l'atttenti
n'est-il pas toujours n'a pas toujours
été le modus opérandi du gouvernement
précédent je m'adresse directement à
vous Monsieur le Premier Ministre où en
sommes-nous vous êtes censé incarner le
renouveau or depuis 7 ans disons-le
franchement la question des outres mèes
n'a jamais abordé sauf sous longue de la
réaction réaction au problèmes
migratoires aux problèmes sécuritaires
aux catastrophes naturelles aux pénu
rideaux aux mouvements sociaux aux
interpellation d'exécutifs locaux je
vous donne ici l'occasion de présenter
un semblant de feuilles de route pour
les outres mes pas pour les intérêts
économiques ni pour leurs vertus
géostratégique pas pour leur conseiller
de faire bouillir de l'eau avant de la
boire mais pour la valorisation de leur
diversité culturelle humaine
linguistique pour le reconnaissance de
leur rôle central dans la préservation
de la biodiversité pour l'épanouissement
de leur population pour les diso de
voter Le Pen en 2027 par dégoût de tout
ce qui se tout ce qui ressemble de près
ou de loin à la macronie je vous donne
ici l'occasion Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de ne plus être en réaction
mais dans l'action monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez dit lors de votre
nomination que vous ameniez l'éducation
avec vous à Matignon ma question est
simple comptez-vous et ce serit là une
première depuis 7 ans amener les AR
mires à
Matignon je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
[Applaudissements]
Ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président davir riman vous n'êtes pas
président de groupe mais je tenais à
vous répondre personnellement parce que
le sujet que vous abordez est absolument
majeur et oui je le dis au cœur de la
feuille de route que je présenterai
devant vous le 30 janvier et de l'action
que je compte conduire en tant que
Premier ministre de la France avec mon
gouvernement j'ai eu l'occasion ces
dernières années d'occuper différentes
fonctions gouvernemental en tant que
secrétaire d'État à la Jeunesse
porte-parole du gouvernement ministre
des comptes publiques et de l'éducation
nationale à chaque fois j'ai eu
l'opportunité la chance de travailler
avec nos territoires ultra marins sur
tous ces enjeux et je le dis je suis
lucide à la fois sur les immenses défis
et vous l'avez rappelé qui sont devant
nous pour ces territoires vous l'avez
indiqué en matière de logement en
matière sociale en matière d'emploi de
mobilité de sécurité
d'immigration aussi en matière
environnementale mais conscient et cide
aussi de la chance extraordinaire que
constituent les territoires ultramarins
pour notre pays en matière de jeunesse
en matière d'innovation de créativité en
matière de souveraineté en matière de
biodiversité et moi je le dis de manière
très claire oui il faut être au côté de
nos territoires ultramarins lorsque
surviennent des drames des crises vous
l'avez rappelé et c'est à ce titre que
mon ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
armanin est en ce moment même à la
Réunion au côté des victimes du cyclone
mais il faut aussi et vous avez
totalement raison le dire être dans la
prospective investir positivement sur
tous les potentiels de nos territoires
ultramarins nous avons par ailleurs un
certain nombre d'échéances majeures
devant nous vous le savez le président
de la République avait annoncé il y a
quelques mois la préparation d'une
grande loi sur Mayot et nous allons y
travailler de la même manière nous avons
des textes institutionnels importants
sur l'avenir de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui nous rassembleront ici dans cet
hémicycle et je sais qu'en guyan
qu'osanti qu'à la Réunion qu'à Mayotte à
Saint-Pierre et miclon ou àcé foutuna
dans tous nos territoires ultramarins il
y a des défis et des enjeux sur lesquels
nous devons investir ensemble donc très
concrètement je recevrai aussi vite que
possible la délégation aux outremèes que
vous présidez je réunirai dans les tous
prochains mois un comité
interministériel aux outremers un sium
pour avancer sur tous ces sujetsl et je
me rendrai aussi vite que possible dans
nos territoires ultramarins et j'espère
que vous me ferai l'honneur de
m'accompagner dans ce déplacement je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
le rendez-vous est pris sachez quand
même qu'il y a des il y a des urgences
et des scandales à régler sur no
territoire au risque de fracture
irréversible je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier fort pour le groupe
socialiste madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues on allait voir ce qu'on
allait voir le président a convoqué hier
soir les français pour je cite son grand
rendez-vous avec la nation mais sur quoi
unit-on une nation sur quelle vision
pour que la France reste la France pour
reprendre la formule sur grandc Zemour
mais la France républicaine n'est pas
une nostalgie elle est un horizon la
volonté chaque jour renouvelé d'avancer
sur le chemin de la liberté de l'égalité
et de la
fraternité les crises se multiplient
elle se cumulent les inégalités explose
c'était le moment de responsabiliser le
CAC 40 avec un discours de vérité en
appelant les plus riches à l'effort
national pour répondre au défis de
l'avenir le voilà le vrai réarmement
civique l'école elle a besoin de nouveau
usussard de la République pas d'uniforme
rendez à nouveau attractif le plus beau
métier du monde soutenez l'école
publique le travail il doit payer il
faut une grande conférence sociale où
tout serait remis à plat pour augmenter
les salaires à commencé par les premiers
de corvet le logement un toit pour tous
devrait être la règle alors que plus de
3 millions de logements restent
aujourd'hui vacants l'accès aux soins il
est temps d'en finir avec les déserts
médicaux de réguler l'installation des
médecins comme c'est le cas pour les
pharmaciens la bifurcation écologique
vos propres experts ont exigé des moyens
rétablissez un ISF climatique la
démocratie c'est d'abord le pluralisme
interdisez la concentration des médias
garantissez l'indépendance des
rédactions merci j'en fini par vous
Monsieur le Premier Ministre plus qu'un
mot vous ne pouvez pas être le simple
collaborateur d'un président vous
souffle merci monsieur le
député la parole
est à Madame Prisc evau porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau
démocratique merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député fort j'avoue être un
peu perplexe parce que je m'attendais à
une question et en réalité j'assiste à
un simulacre de discours de politique
générale mais soit allons-y
allons-y allons-y vous qui n'avez bien
évidemment vous qui n'avez vous qui
n'avez bien évidemment jamais été aux
responsabilités vous qui n'avez jamais
pu bien évidemment faire des choses pour
la France que ce soit ici ailleurs
aujourd'hui ou avant mais regardons les
sujets dans le fond parce que les gens
n'attendent pas qu'on crie mais plutôt
qu'on leur réponde et nous avons
aujourd'hui cette responsabilité de
pouvoir adresser des sujets de fond face
au défis auquels sont confrontés nos
concitoyens vous parlez de
redistribution et bien oui nous sommes
un des pays où il y a le plus de
redistribution et cette redistribution
elle existe parce que bien évidemment il
y a effectivement des personnes qui
peuvent distribuer et participer à cette
redistribution et cette solidarité
nationale ce n'est pas en pointant du
doigt qu'on y arrivera et ce n'est pas
en pointant du doigt qu'on arrivera à
créer la cohésion nationale dont nous
avons tant besoin en ce moment notamment
vous parlez d'augmenter les salaires oui
et encore oui monsieur fort oui mais
pour augmenter les salaires encore
faut-il que les emplois existent et
c'est ce à quoi nous nous sommes
employés dès 2017 à lutter contre un
fléo que vous avez renoncer à travailler
que vous avez considéré comme une
fatalité qui s'appelle le chômage de
longue durée et le chômage de masse
c'est une réalité vous pouvez souffler
nous l'avons fait donc encore une fois
je pense qu'aujourd'hui même si vous
faites partie d'un groupe d'opposition
nous pouvons encore nous retrouver pour
travailler ensemble non pas pour
travailler sur les gos et faciliter les
gos mais pour défendre des idéos que je
pense un jour nous avions en
commun je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame cine
CALV pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre de la Culture votre
nomination a été une surprise pour
certains beaucoup même les mêmes sont
déjà surpris par votre détermination à
vous battre pour l'accès à la culture
l'accès à la culture parce que c'est un
véritable moyen d'émancipation et
d'égalité la majorité présidentielle est
fière d'y œuvrer depuis 2017 pour les
plus jeunes par la mise en place du Pass
Culture ou encore par l'éducation
artistique et culturelle à l'école hier
le président de la République qui a
d'ailleurs fait référence et souhaite la
renforcer par le théâtre et par
l'histoire de l'art il a aussi fait
référence au rôle des célébrations nos
hommages qui rappellent et constituent
progressivement notre mémoire
collective madame la ministre vous
prenez vos fonctions en 2024 quand le
monde aura plusieurs occasions de nous
regarder nous la France dans des
événements de fierté majeur les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques la
réouverture de Notre-Dame le 80e
anniversaire de débarquement ou encore
le Sommet de la Francophonie comment
faire que la culture rayonne pour tous
ici et en dehors de nos frontières en
même temps l'accès à la culture partout
et pas qu'à Paris c'est grâce aux
artistes aux festivals aux associations
ces cultures vivantes que je souhaite
remercier pour leur action partout tout
le temps l'accès partout c'est aussi le
contact culturel permis par
l'audiovisuel et le numérique
quelle place accorderez-vous à ces
créations comment tirer le meilleur
avantage de leur pouvoir de diffusion
d'interaction sans les risques de leur
dérive vous défendez la culture
populaire derrière cette notion je veux
vous adresser une question comment
souhaitez-vous œuvrer pour la
reconnaissance de la culture de chacune
et chacun d'entre nous madame la
ministre comment votre feuille de route
s'inscrira-t-elle dans le chemin tracé
depuis 2017 comment relèvera-t-il les
défis de la
comme de notre nation je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma ch collègue la parole
est à Madame Rach ministre de la
[Applaudissements]
Culture madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
ch
Céline au moment où je prends la tête du
ministère de la Culture la liste en mar
je trouve deux grandes
questions la première comment consolider
notre modèle
culturel le soutenir comme tout soutenir
tous nos acteurs culturels qui font la
richesse de notre pays et le bonheur de
nos concitoyens dans un monde qui bouge
rapidement et qui peut-être et vous le
savez tous extrêmement
menaçant d'autre part comment faire en
sorte que notre modèle culturel soit au
cœur de nos notre modèle de société et
on le voit tous et tous les jours
combien il est remis en cause notamment
par certains de ce côté-là de
l'hémicycle dans notre pays dans notre
pays trop de jeunes se disent encore le
théâtre les musées la lecture ce n'est
pas pour moi la lecture c'est ce qui
permet et la culture c'est ce qui permet
à chacun de se construire de devenir un
citoyen éclairé
je sais justement par mon expérience moi
je n'ai hérité de rien monsieur
[Applaudissements]
marlex je sais je sais par mon
expérience je sais par mon
expérience que
l'émancipation que l'intégration je sais
ça vous parle pas que la liberté
passe par la
culture et cette chance elle doit être
offerte à tous et partout sur tous les
territoires voilà la mission que m'a
confié le président de la
République et je vous le dis et je vous
le dis je l'accomplirai avec
détermination avec honneur partout sur
le territoire et avec vous tous merci
beaucoup madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
un peu de silence s'il vous
plaît la parole est à Madame Dani auonau
pour le groupe la France
insoumise
le merci madame la Présidente le 29
décembre 2023 l'Afrique du Sud a déposé
devant la Cour internationale de justice
en vertu de la convention de 1948 pour
la prévention et la répression du crime
de génocide une requête contre Israël
concernant les exactions commises par
son gouvernement d'extrême droite contre
la population palestinenne de Gaza le 11
janvier 2024 les plédroiries de la
République sud-africaine ont fait
l'objet d'un scandaleux boycotte des
médias occidentaux et français il
s'agissait pourtant d'un événement
historique à la portée géopolitique et
juridique inédit l'État dont la
légitimité initiale est fondé sur la
conscience du génocide commis contre les
Juifs par l'Allemagne nazi et ses
complices et aujourd'hui accusé de le le
reproduire contre les Palestiniens et
les palestiniennes les gouvernements
occidentaux qui n'ont de cesse de donner
des leçons de démocratie et de droits
humains au reste du monde font preuve de
complaisance à son égard quand il ne lui
apporte pas comme les États-Unis
d'Amérique un soutien militaire et
financier c'est l'Afrique du Sud la
nation arc-en-ciel qui a subi
l'esclavage la colonisation et
l'apartide dont le peuple a consit sa
liberté en au terme du très long et très
dur lutte de libération nationale c'est
ce pays africain qui a sauvé notre
honneur à tous et toutes en défendant à
la fois la cause du peuple palestinien
celle du droit international et de
l'humanité toute entière nous lui en
sommes profondément reconnaissants et
reconnaissantes
à Gaza expliquait une de ses avocates se
déroule le premier génocide de
l'histoire dont les victimes diffusent
en temps réel leur propre destruction
dans l'espoir désespéré et jusqu'à
présent vain de voir le monde faire
quelque chose si elle veut être en
cohérence avec ses valeurs la France
doit urgemment emboîer le pas à
l'Afrique du Sud comme l'ont déjà fait
plus de 50 pays dans le monde elle doit
soutenir la requête sud-africaine qui
demande notamment à la Cour
internationale de Justice d'enjoindre le
gouvernement israélien à suspendre
immédiatement ces opérations militaires
elle doit également appliquer au niveau
national et européen des sanctions qui
s'imposent Monsieur le Premier Ministre
l'histoire nous regarde elle ne sera pas
tendre avec celles et ceux qui savaient
et n'ont rien fait plus jamais ça pour
personne je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane séjourné ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires
étrangères
merci merci Madame madame la présidente
madame la députée auonau le 7 octobre
dernier Israël a subi une attaque
terroriste barbare 1200 morts des
mutilations des viols des assassinats
d'enfants des civils israéliens ont été
visés pour ceux qu'ils
sont 41 français sont morts dans ces
conditions atroces nous leur rendrons
hommage le 7 février et tro encore de
nos compatriotes sont autage à Gaza et
nous faisons tout pour les en sortir
qu'avez-vous dit en réaction à ces
crimes terroristes je vous cite le Hamas
est un groupe de résistance qui se
définit comme tel madame obono c'est ça
le scandale madame
obono le Président de la République lui
a toujours tenu une position d'équilibre
je vous la rappelle condamner le
terroriste ce que vous n'arrivez
toujours pas à faire madame
auonvre à un cesser le feu immédiat pour
permettre de garantir les souffrance des
Palestiniens rétablir un horizon
politique pour avancer vers deux état au
sujet monsieur ministre 2 secondes
est-ce que vous pourriez faire silence
et écouter la réponse s'il vous plaît je
vous en remercie mais vous ne choisissez
pas vos réponses ils ne choisissent pas
leurs questions monsieur le ministre
nous éoutppelle la position de la France
madame
auonau rétablir un horizon politique
pour avancer vers deux états et ce sujet
sera au cœur des discussions de la
réunion du Conseil de sécurité que je
présiderai mardi prochain à New York
pour ce qui est de la Cour
internationale de justice puisque c'est
votre question jy
[Applaudissements]
Allis nous disons fermement aux
Israéliens le respect du droit s'impose
à tous les frappes systématiques à Gaza
doivent cesser mais les mots madame
auono ont un sens les mots ont un sens
et accuser l'État juif de génocide c'est
franchir un seuil moral
on ne peut exploiter la notion de
génocide à des fins politiques c'est
notre position constante nous l'avons
dit quand la Russie a utilisé ce
justificatif pour justifier
l'injustifiable sa guerre en Ukraine
merci beaucou alors en conclusion madame
la Présidente j'ai été interrompu en
conclusion nous n'avons pas de leçon à
recevoir de votre parti vous n'êtes pas
au clair ni sur leas ni sur
Gaza merci Monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Ministre madame auonau s'il vous plaît
la parole est à Madame Julie lernous
pour le groupe
écologiste ma question s'adresse à Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie donc
maintenant aussi ministre de l'Énergie
car où est passé le climat complètement
absent du grand oral du président de la
République complètement absent aussi du
remanement ministériel le climat a tout
simplement disparu pourtant le
réchauffement climatique lui n'a pas
disparu 2023 a été l'année la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée inondation
canicules incendies les catastrophes se
multiplient et les habitants du pas
decalais en sont les dernières victimes
et que faites-vous rien à défaut d'agir
vous prétendez être les premiers en
Europe à vous emparer de l'adaptation au
réchauffement climatique mais de qui se
moque-t-on la seule action de Monsieur
Béchu est de courir pour constater les
dégâts la fenêtre de tir se referme de
plus en plus vite et que faites-vous
rien votre première action Monsieur le
Maire comme nouveau ministre de
l'énergie c'est de supprimer le climat
et les énergies renouvelable de la loi
l'écologie ne sert visiblement plus le
discours politique de la macronie pour
contr contrer l'extrême droite ordre
armement uniforme immigration au
contraire vous avez définitivement
décidé de vous réapproprier le
vocabulaire de l'extrême droite et
l'écologie de fait n'y a pas sa place
une régression totale complète et
coupable la priorité politique devrait
être de baisser la consommation de
rénover le logement de faire payer les
plus gros pollueurs comme total mais
vous vous laissez la situation se
dégrader dans l'indifférence pour
protéger votre sacroin de croissance
économique et faire divers avec des
solutions technolutionnistes avec en
tête le nucléaire exite la sobriété exit
les renouvelables exite les associations
environnementales exit les normes
européennes et climatiques un retour en
arrière de 17 ans absolument terrifiant
à rebours de l'histoire et de la réalité
scientifique monsieur le ministre
assumez-vous aujourd'hui êtes les
meilleurs amis des
climatosceptiques merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industriel et
numérique madame la présidente madame la
députée larnaau je veux vous
rassurer les résultats ils sont là ils
sont incontestables la France a réduit
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
4 % c'est le pays qui a le plus accéléré
sur sa réduction de l'émission de gaz à
effet de
serre vous regardez toutes les nations
européennees et vous regardez le pays
qui émet le moins de tonnes de CO2 par
unité de production industrielle vous
trouvez quel pays la France qui est le
pays le plus vertueux du point de vue de
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
Europe vous regardez notre mix
énergétique et vous constatez que le
pays qui a le mix énergétique qui est le
plus favorable à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est une
nouvelle fois la France madame la
députée ne doutez pas de ma
détermination totale à accélérer la
transition climatique dans les nouvelles
fonctions qui sont les miennes et à
faire en sorte que notre énergie soit
l'énergie la plus décarbonée en Europe
que nous tenions nos objectifs 50 % des
réduction des effets de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 et la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 avec un troisème
objectif que je rajoute une belle
ambition pour la France être la première
nation industrielle décarbonée en Europe
à échéance 2040 moi je n'ai qu'un seul
mot et devrais vous rassurer accélérer
accélérer sur la sobriété vous avez
raison c'est un point absolument majeur
de la stratégie climatique qui a été
définie par le Président de la
République et je commence volontairement
par là oui la sobriété est nécessaire
oui l'efficacité énergétique et est
nécessairire parce que personne ne peut
accepter qu'une industrie émette de
l'énergie fatale sans qu'elle soit
récupérée pour réduire une nouvelle fois
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
oui nous accélérerons sur les
renouvelables oui nous accélérerons sur
l'éolien sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques sur la géothermie sur
les pompes à chaleur sur tout ce qui
permet de gagner cette bataille du
climat et oui ce sera peut-être notre
seul point de divergence nous acc on
aussi sur la réalisation des six
nouveaux EP réacteurs nucléaires car
l'énergie nucléaire c'est de l'énergie
décarbonée et c'est aussi une victoire
contre le réchauffement climatique merci
monsieur le
ministre et enfin la parole est à Madame
Marina Ferrari pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ma question
porte sur l'assurance des collectivités
vous le savez nos collectivités sont
confronté à des difficultés pour
s'assurer et la situation ce 2024 est
très pré occupante s'il y a quelques
mois ces difficultés portaient davantage
sur l'assurance statutaire et RH et sur
les villes petites et moyennes dans
certaines zones très exposés tous les
risques toutes les strates de
collectivité et tout le territoire
national sont aujourd'hui concernés 2000
d'entre elles seraient sans couverture
dans mon département la Savoie une
enquête montre que 33 % des communes
interrogées sont confronté à la
résiliation unilatérale de leur contrat
à l'augmentation des primes ou des
franchises de 25 jusqu'à 100 % en
particulier sur les dommages au bien la
responsabilité civile et les flottes
automobiles nos collectivités sont donc
conduites à s'auto-assurer avec des
risques financiers énormes cette
situation s'explique par un marché de
l'assurance qui est déficitaire une
sinistralité conjoncturelle de plus en
plus importante en témoigne les 200
millions d'euros de dégâts qui ont été
constatés sur les émeutes de cet été
mais surtout par une sinistralité
climatique qui explose elle a triplé
entre 2018 et 2022 par rapport à la
période précédente le coût des dégâts
des catastrophes naturelles pourrait
atteindre 3 milliards d'euros par an
d'ici 2050 pour autant l'État n'est pas
resté sourd et a annoncé des mesures une
mission gouvernementale sur
l'assurabilité des collectivité conduite
par Alain chrétien et jean- dagess a été
nommé ces conclusions sont attendues
pour fin avril et nous conduirons
certainement à un travail législatif
mais dans l'intervalle le nombre de
collectivités impacté ne cesse de
s'accroître et les catastrophes
naturelles se multiplient j'aurais une
pensée pour nos compatriotes du pcalais
et de la Réunion et pour leurs élus
locaux qui sont en première ligne dans
la gestion de l'après au moment où les
discussions budgétaires sont en cours
dans nos communes comment l'État
compte-il travailler ce sujet avec les
représentants des associations d'élus
comment envisagez-vous le soutien aux
collectivités qui se trouve sans
couverture assurancielle nos élus
partout ont besoin d'être rassurés et
soutenus je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Prisc EV
porte-parole du gouvernement et ministre
en charge du renouveau
démocratique merci madame la présidente
madame la députée Ferrari je me permets
de répondre au nom du ministre
Christophe Béchu qui est retenu en ce
moment même au Sénat mais voici la
réponse qu'il vous aurait adressée s'il
avait pu être là avec vous aujourd'hui
oui un certain nombre d'événements
récents notamment l'épisode des
violences urbaines ont à nouveau mis à
jour la fragilité des systèmes
d'assurance des collectivités
territorial comme vous l'avez très
justement indiqué oui le sujet est
structurel un nombre significatif
d'appels d'offr sont infructueux pardon
et les prix et les franchises augmentent
ce phénomène est effectivement lié aux
risques émergents climatiques sociaux
cyber mais aussi aux risques juridiques
et judiciaaires c'est également lié à
l'équilibre et à la rentabilité d'un
marché de l'assurance resserré autour de
deux principaux assureurs le marché de
la réassurance sur lequel ils sont
adossés c'est lui-même durcit vous avez
raison de dissocier la réponse que doit
apporter le gouvernement entre le court
terme et le moyen terme sur le moyen
terme le ministre de l'Économie Bruno
Lemire et le ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur Béchu donc seront
très attentifs aux préconisations que
soumettront messieurs chrétien et daguès
il leur revient d'esquisser un cadre qui
permettra aux collectivités de s'assurer
effectivement contre les risques
auxquels elles sont exposées nous
devrons discuter le cas échéant avec
vous le Parlement des mesures à prendre
pour y parvenir sur le court terme pour
répondre à l'urgence le gouvernement
pilote un groupe de travail avec les
assureurs pour suivre le rythme des
dédommagements et éviter les
résiliations sèches avec ave l'appui de
la direction générale du Trésor cet
effort a déjà produit des effets nous
sommes passés de 3,5 du taux de
résiliation en 2022 à 2,9 en 2023 nous
avons étendu le champ des compétences
également du Médiateur des assurances
qui s'empare désormais des litige dans
le cadre des contrats existants je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la séance de question au
gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendu